hannover namens luca und meine lieben
freunde gesetz bereits im titel
eingeblendet
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
mensch luca was ist los was hast du
wieder gemacht was er angestellt gar
nichts
also hoffe ich es soll nämlich in diesem
heutigen video hier von mir nicht um
mich gehen sondern um den hate den
andere leute zu spüren bekommen was sie
allerdings gar nicht wollen
ich glaube ich habe mich ein bisschen um
missverständlich ausgedrückt aber
empfang einfach mal an wenn hier wurde
von ard brisant ein bild gepostet mit
der info dass justin bieber an einer
halbseitigen gesichtslähmung leidet wenn
ich das sehen würde würde ich mir denken
mensch der junge hat den übelsten stress
überhaupt ist mit die bekannteste person
auf dem kompletten planeten und das ist
ein gesundheitlicher einschnitt der dein
leben verändern kann mit dieser ganzen
stress thematik und dass er deswegen
halbseitige gesichtslähmung hat et
cetera pp ich will einfach nur denken
gute besserung bruder ich hoffe wir ist
gesund weil ich ihn über alles feier
aber auch wenn ich ihn nicht feiern
würde mensch das ist ein mensch der soll
gesundheit haben der sitz nichts
riesiges falsch gemacht was man sich
wünscht er wäre krank oder was weiß ich
aber nee die deutschen schreiben also
kommt oder wie also ich kann den typen
absolut nicht leiden mag seine musik
überhaupt nicht das ist heftig und
wirklich einzeln in der sache ich bin
schon gute besserung
wenn du deinen nachbarn nicht leiden
können und er wird ein herzinfarkt
kriegen wird auch hingehen und sagen
eigentlich kann ich dich nicht leider
kann ich mal erst hier hatte er die
brisant gepostet dass helene fischer
eventuell bald ihr tv comeback bei
florian silbereisen feiert es juckt mich
ehrlich gesagt auch überhaupt gar nicht
trotzdem würde ich niemals so ein
kommentar darunter schreiben ein sack
reis umgefallen finde ich gerade
interessanter bro du hast denn der bio
ausbildung kinderpflegerin stehen hat
man da nichts besseres zu tun als
sonntag unter solche beiträge zu
schreiben hier wird gepostet dass bill
gates bisher nur in diesem jahr allein
23 milliarden euro verlust gemacht hat
und die kommentare darunter war mir
kommen gleich die tränen was juckt uns
normalos dass wir haben dank unserer
tollen regierungen auch verluste aber
das interessiert ja keinen der obrigkeit
wir müssen dringend spendenaufrufe
machen kam
das thema zu tun
bill gates hat bestimmt nicht gesagt
werden schwächt die schwachen und zur
preis und preis niemand von dieser
reichen menschen hat auch irgendwie sich
darüber beschwert dass er verlust
gemacht hat denn auch das muss man ja
ganz gut sagen buchverluste sind nicht
reale verluste die haben nicht alle
milliarden auf dem konto dieser etlichen
gelder da alles und dann verlieren sie
was sonst von kontowechsel
guckt euch mein 1 x 1 zum börse einmal
gutes sinnbild dieser die wissen
wahrscheinlich nicht mal die wörter
geschrieben wird olaf scholz verdient
30.000 euro pro monat er kann ruhig mal
was an die wo einen sozialen beruf
ausüben abgeben hauptsache hätten aber
nicht mal richtig deutsch können jeder
kennt klaas heufer umlauf als moderator
nun war der 38-jährige den schritt ins
filmgeschäft wie ernst meint er es mit
der schauspielerei ich will klaas
heufer-umlauf jetzt wirklich nicht in
schutz nehmen
ich finde ihn selber nicht lustig aber
das ist einer der bekanntesten
moderatoren in deutschland und der typ
hat einfach geschafft
trotzdem kommen dann solche kommentare
das komische darüber ist ja dass wir
nicht mehr lustig ist das wird mit
doppel s geschrieben erst mal an der
stelle selbst schuld seine und witzige
alberne art geht mir auf den keks und
wer hat nach seiner meinung gefragt den
konnte ich noch nie leiden schreibt
alles gartenparadies das ist ihr vieh
tel ich kann deinen garten nicht leiden
hier wurden bild von matthias
schweighöfer mit seiner freundin
gepostet die in dieser drei jahren
zusammen sind und irgendwie meine
hochzeit nach der es gibt wirklich
nichts was mich weniger jungen könnte
aber ich würde niemals so tief sinken
und das unter seinen beitrag posten
aber dass eine andere person mit meinem
namen und zwar schreibt y punkt luca ich
mag ihn nicht trotzdem alles gute ich
mag ihn nicht wünsche ihnen aber
trotzdem dass sie zusammen bleiben das
wird auch hier mit doppel s geschrieben
man die hätten aber können nicht mal
deutsch schreiben das war ein beitrag wo
der sohn von david beckham gesagt hat
dass der karriere druck bezogen auf
seinen vater ihnen halt echt sehr zu
schaffen macht welche karriere bisher
tja alles mögliche versucht und meist
schnell wieder beendet
höchstwahrscheinlich eben aufgrund
dieses karriere drucks welche karriere
sohn von ja
er kann nichts dafür dass er der sohn
von david beckham es und wenn du dann
plötzlich 18 version in der
öffentlichkeit stehst und für dich
selbst dein handeln aufkommen muss und
jeder guckt über die finger und du hast
dieses riesen erbe david beckham über
dir stehenden wow das ist klar dass da
druck kommt niemand kann was dafür wie
oder als was er geboren wurde war kauft
euch leben alter hier wird gepostet dass
pedro und seine ex irgendwie wieder ein
paar sind so leer hat lustigerweise
genau der gleiche typ von gerade drunter
kommentiert hauptsache die teure uhr ist
auf dem foto ja das ist das bild
vielleicht waren sie bei oma an ostern
und die oma hat gesagt mensch in china
gerade dieses album habe ich mal kurz
ein foto soll er dann denke das wird
vielleicht irgendwie von bild gepostet
und ich nehme mal besser die hohe ab nee
und auch wenn die gut drauf ist mein
gott der macht musik jetzt das
erarbeitet und werde damit flexen will
unter stolz drauf ist dann lasst ihn
doch ganz liebe grüße an der stelle
pietro als morlock als nächstes kommen
wir zu einem video von meinem tik tok
highlight zu tauen denen ich glaube ich
noch nie erwähnt habe luca highlights
aufdeckt opfer sofort begannen anlauf
nehmen ich hab
jetzt haben wir so viel zeit hatten wir
noch ein bisschen hier sehr gut
derzeit schon gesehen ganz normales
gaming video wie ich vor geist gespielt
aber auf den zweit kanal und halb voll
verkackt habe er kann allerdings
kommentare unter mit 31 likes von wegen
trends spieler
wo ich mir denke
er will mir gerade ans bein pissen und
mir sagen dass ich ein trend spieler sei
von wegen dieses spiel ist jetzt gerade
bekannt nur deswegen spielt luca das
jetzt am 16.9 2020 habe ich dieses video
hochgeladen
[Musik]
zu dem zeitpunkt dieser aufnahme war das
spiel vorbei ist gerade mal seit vier
wochen draußen
also das erst mal um diesen trend
spieler kommentar komplett auseinander
zu nehmen aber auch wenn ich das spiel
theoretisch ist von der woche entdeckt
hätte na und
denen
ich verstehe diese ganze trend thematik
wirklich überhaupt nicht es ist doch
einfach cool wenn ein kunde dann sagt
ich spiele das jetzt auch dann freut
euch doch das jetzt beide das gleiche
spiel spielen könnt hier zum beispiel
promi vielleicht gebraucht hat dass
julia mit einem neuen mädel gesehen
wurde darunter wird geschrieben café
buja wo sonst das ist das influenza café
numero uno da geht man hin wenn man
gesehen werden möchte ich ja oder wenn
man einen guten kaffee trinken will
sollte
sich diese leute die in der
öffentlichkeit stehen reichweite damit
zu hause einschließen in diesem video
hier beispielsweise was ich euch
aufgrund von urheberrecht nicht
einwenden kann ging es aber auf jeden
fall darum dass julian dieses neue mädel
mit in das ferienhaus von denen noch
spanien gebracht hat sondern kommentiert
da wieder jemand runter interessiert
kein schwein doch tut es das war die
trennung in deutschland bisher des
kompletten jahres tik tok war voll damit
die hatten kumuliert milliarden aufrufe
auf diese ganzen tag box dazu die dazu
viral gehen die youtube-videos die news
dass junge menge menschen war folgt doch
nicht einer promi seite mit news auf
instagram um dann zu kommentieren dass
sich bobby beiträge und news auf
instagram nicht was ist das für eine
doppelmoral hier ging es darum dass eine
künstliche intelligenzen menschenrechte
haben will und das war logischerweise
nur die überschrift weil das ist die
bild -zeitung die wollen trägern in dem
artikel ging es dann darum dass ein
mitarbeiter gesagt hat hey ich hab hier
was entwickelt das hat gefühle das
braucht menschenrechte und der
mitarbeiter wegen wie pem pem und wird
noch gefeiert
diese bild-leser lisa allerdings nur die
überschrift und kommentieren dann direkt
abschalten oder alter denn melanie jetzt
noch in zukunft sagt ich hab rechte
stelle mich nicht auf sturm
die ich nach timbuktu und arbeiter auf
einer farm so ein quatsch ehrlich
lest einfach
mehr als überschrift lest euch den
artikel durch und im besten falle nicht
bei der bildzeitung sorry aber diese
dummheit einiger menschen ist echt
unendlich und an der stelle würde ich
damit auch ehrlich gesagt das heutige
video beenden weil daneben freundes tut
mir leid das ist jetzt nicht so ein
kurzes knackiges unterhaltungs
wiederwahl sondern wirklich ein bisschen
länger und ein bisschen ernst aber es
muss irgendwie mal gesagt werden und da
bin ich auch ganz ehrlich ich stehe zu
diesem video zu 100 prozent ich werde
menge hierfür bekommen dass ich das hier
so sagen weil ich auch sehr ausfallend
war aber es ist mir scheißegal
denn das geht in vielen vielen szenarien
hier in die richtung cybermobbing das
sollte teilweise wirklich strafrechtlich
verfolgt werden meiner ansicht nach denn
das internet ist kein rechtsfreier raum
und diese personen die das schreiben die
sind übels hohl und ich schreibe das ein
blutroter wir sind übels verbittert
diese menschen diese einfach kalt aber
die wissen auch nicht wie das bei diesen
leuten ankommt und wie die sich diese
kommentaren zu herzen nehmen
wir alle können dazu beitragen indem ihr
einfach solche kommentare wenn wir sie
sehen einfach mal melden oder dann
darunter schreiben mich juckt ich finde
es schön dass die beiden zusammen sind
ich finde es schade dass der kranke sich
freue mich wenn er wieder gesund ist ich
wünsche ihm gute besserung aber warum
sagst du leidest ihn nie oder was weiß
ich es jedoch nicht
mich würde es freuen wenn ich das video
irgendwie an freunde weiter schickt und
das irgendwie vielleicht viral geht so
dass vielleicht ein paar leute sich in
ernster nehmen und wir müssen was
verändern können aber sorry es musste
mal gesagt werden wir sehen uns morgen
im neuen video wieder